deux expositions qui se trouve sur dont
speaker qu'office est un homme qui doit
se rendre à des réunions travail et perd
importante et pour cela il doit passer
d'un système de sécurité très élaboré le
tout avec des contrôles dégueulasse est
parti alors effective ou à temps et je
vous prends un contrôle il faut vraiment
que j'apprenne à un changement de caméra
pour bien achever ses bas comme ça qu'on
marche [ __ ] ok je contrôle mon camp
avec ça donc je peux boire et menace
état de l'exercice d'un brouillard h
projet de double fine bras le truc c'est
vous voyez à le badge qui est sûre note
qu il faut le coller à cette porte
[ __ ] relève toi mais tu peux te
relever il ya des mains des mains tu
mets la paume barthet tu veux trop levé
je te jure avec bus qui l'on peut se
relever c'est sur rien on va se lever
contre le mur on va recommencer
voici passe on va y arriver c'est
fantastique parce je vais te tuer
monsieur propre là ok speed run on n'a
pas le temps le café on le voit en mai
dans les yeux on s'en bat les couilles
oh oui ok le match dimanche à nos plaies
auquel il faut passer le même porte d'un
bus pas avec ça s'appelle rendement de
soi rezaï a pas de bip là donc on est
bon on peut direct passé non detec le
badge à des doigts il sort avec ton
crâne butin au oui j'ai coulé mongongu
fessiers obèses ok on peut continuer
squat times qui devra faire avec move
your bottes lt pu se lève stick mais les
gars faut se pencher le boîtier mes mecs
poèmes c'était prévu pour la sécu cette
pause mais qu'est ce qu'il fait barrette
à l'establishment pose naturelle attend
petit entraînement fictifs comme chez
pour remonter le maire hier face à un
moyen de remonter avec un voyage ça
marche ça marche on y va comme ça on y
va comme ça on n'a jamais vu a dit bart
marché comme un crabe eux aussi
précisément mais à la maison mais non je
suis deg et tue pas le faire monsieur
poids à la une
à la 2 à la 3 c'est quoi ce bordel à
laisser passer
iolo c'est quoi cette mode qui fait
l'amour à du café les mecs ça
normalement tu peux marcher je les ai
déjà fait quand j'étais jeune et con
seiller
il fait tout puis sur un baril s'est pas
passé un [ __ ] de portiques soit
possible je suis hyper qu'on en fait
c'est tout nas oui ok c'est passé ric
verticale et challenge à c'est quoi ce
délire will be puis est choqué ok
position pendant que je faisais pareil
pour valider ma carte de cantine au
lycée c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
beaucoup d'amis level 5 t que s'il devra
s'asseoir avec maintenant b nommé mais
qui abuse pas jack et l'employé qui se
fait chier à faire ça pour me faire
chier et ce comme super bizarre je pense
que du coup pour s'asseoir tu te penches
en avant et ensuite tu t'assois comme ça
leval 6e rang mme krieber mais mike
favre est scanné des quoi calmer vous
pas de [ __ ] de souci j'ai la technique
ne vous en faites pas ça c'est comme
quand tu déplaces les palettes
intermarché j'ai fait mon stage de
troisième intermarché je sais ce que
c'est voilà bah c'était plutôt déplacé
les palettes intermarché 2007 faut faire
du limbo c'est parti on tape tous les
malades
la chute a été terrible jeu par la chute
le truc je prends le cas fin pas la
chute
parra j'ai adoré ta blague squeeze merci
tu es gentil toi j'en viens à moto
soutenir et que perso un jeu vidéo
oh non je vous fais pas vite me consoler
j'autorise un passé le tt ya les oiseaux
dans ma chambre le 28 dans glee
qu'est ce que c'est que ça what we alors
oui prouverait ce [ __ ] de portiques
alice te plaît s'te plaît s'il te plaît
mon chou
j'arrive à la réunion les habits chauds
fort tard à level noves take two step
il va falloir passer une marche c'est ça
hop là on se remet et voilà incroyable
j'espère au moins que joël titre
d'employés du moins mon gars level this
balance bim parfitt à sa part au cirque
ouais
je peux sauter ou pas vous pensez à
temps ça la vraie question
oui level on zigzague attendirent et 46
le parcours au concours d'animaux ou
morissette fait sauter son caniche de
dix ans de 30 cm nous fait sauter
monsieur propre [ __ ] c'est tellement
beau ce qui se passe est tellement
grosse qu'on vit tous ensemble avant
dernier level bauxite jeu censé faire
quoi la mecque ne marchera pas la
fameuse technique du de la femme
mais comment on fait à temps il pose une
colle la dernière personne que j'avais
entendu dire ça c'était ma mère et six
en position foetale [ __ ] on aime en
fait allez allez allez est ainsi je
plonge dans pieds mais je m'affaire bien
la voilà pour tuer écoulé à cette plaque
arrière jusqu'à la plaque qui tu as fait
vale met bas mais je peux pas faire
mieux la [ __ ] on n'a jamais vu
quelqu'un est tombé comme ça valide mon
gros boules de chauffe valley non boules
de choses se plaigent howie et réunion
mais voici le val 13 le test final
ah ça c'est tout ce qui est autour du
cirque vous connais bien nous voilà on
est passé bon ok les gars stationne la
technique un super simple tu équilibre
toujours ton corps tu commences à lever
le pied droit tu équilibre avec le but
bien sûr comme dans la vraie vie tu
tombes sur toi-même futur oppose à temps
je suis dit qu'est la quelle on est pas
mal et un employé du mois un bon gars
mais là c'est super pour moi c'est un de
ces scandales je quitte sa page dans une
autre boîte une autre boîte dans
laquelle ira pas mais qui se fait xiam
compliquer la vie tous les jours [ __ ]
non attends je fait carrément en
équilibre alors allez je ne tire c'est
parti pour la rue ouimet lost ya pas de
ces vidéos sur don't feel your koffi ne
fait pas tomber du café vous aviez tous
nominés n'était pas les deux ça vous a
plu [ __ ] j'ai trouvé que
pardon je trouve qu'il fait vieux et les
super marrant cette image en témoigne je
crois que parmi tous les jeux qui
utilisent la technique des contrôles un
peu flou qu'il faut faire des positions
bizarres ton perso pour ce faire marrer
passé le meilleur alors sauté une
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien tient
tout le monde dise oh oh non non c'est
l'imitation nul